okay um
our next contestant will be wilford
gangbo from ucla
and he's going to tell us about the
master equation for mean field games yes
thanks
the presentation
it is a pleasure to be here to
participate in this workshop and i would
like to
thank
katie and simone for the
invitation
so i am going to start with a system of
equation which i prepare in gamer theory
and then
i will
say what i want to do with it
so here i have a notation
so p2
of rd
is the set of new
second moment
and
i will assume that
i am giving a function
h from rd
cross body
cross
b2 of rd
to r
which i am going to call it hamiltonian
and
i am also given a function g
from rd
cross p2
rd
r
which i'm going to call it terminal
value
function
so it will be a terminal value function
at time t
so
zero t
is an interval
time interval
during which
the game
will be played
and uh i am going to
take two parameter epsilon
beta
greater than zero so this parameter this
one will appear in front of your
laplacian and that one will appear in
front of some from something which look
like
a laplacian
so fixed n
greater than two
a natural number
and
we want to find
find
u i
from
zero t
plus
rd
add the cursor the end time
to r
set that
partial derivative respect to time of ui
minus the sum
j
from 1 to n
gradient with respect to p
one over n minus one
the sum
j
is not i
delta s
j inner product
gradient
with respect to sj
minus h
of x i
s i
your ui
one over n minus one
with some
isd
plus epsilon
laplacian
with respect to x
y
plus
beta the sum
over j
k
represents
radian with respect to st
respect to s k
okay so let me pause that here and make
some comment
and we are going to impose that
u
i
of t
i of capital t
x
equal to
g i
d s i
one over n minus one
this sum
and this will be done for i
okay so
this term look very strange
let me check the sign
minus minus plus
so when you are familiar with a hamilton
jacobi equation when you write the
continuity equation
the velocity is this
and so
this whole thing
is a directional derivative
so you differentiate the ui
of t
with respect to
a path
s
i of t
you differentiate that with respect to
time
and
you
assume that the s i is a flow which came
from
this velocity
and so this is how you get this strange
expression
so the last term
product should be gradient ui
yes
yes
but if you take u equal to v
this is what i tell my students that
it's not a mistake i do that on purpose
to see if people are from
okay so
this
come from the factor data
you have a n player
and each of them are affected by uh
noises which are different so
you have a noise
wi
associated to player i
and then this term comes from the fact
that
you have
a one noise which all of them share
so this is called the individual noise
and that is called the common noise
now
observe that
here
i can rewrite this expression
as
the sum over i
trace gradient s i
i can write it as laplacian x
ui
plus this sum
g is not k
we trace
uranium
sk
sk
and
this term
this step is going to help you
improve regularity
and this stem is going to destroy
regularity right if you like to look at
in term of fourier
transform
but when you add up these two and you
compute the fourier transform form you
get upside k minus psi j
square
negative
and so
it is non-negative which means that it
should not create singularity but it
should not improve singularity and
if you add
this epsilon when epsilon is strictly
positive then you are back to a
situation where you can
uh improve your
regularity property this is a wire
most result on existence of solution
they require epsilon to be strictly
positive
now
the difference between here and and
there
so here player i
is choosing is his strategy
and the other player
um may do something different so for the
value function of each player the player
is making this some decision
for himself herself but here the other
player they have
a collective
decision which are excluded player ah
if you replace
this
by one over n
sum
delta
s j
then you get it very easy
you get an easier problem so the
difficulty come from this
difference
and this is why
when you are working with measure which
are absolutely continuous
which we measure which have no atom you
see no difference between this and that
and this is why you get the existence of
solution in
in
that case
with the specific structure of the
hamiltonians you have in mind because
you know for example the
the the way you've written that touch
and it has knowledge of the location of
the point side is that correct
first coordinate but the point is that
the specific structure of the questions
he have in mind the fact that it has
knowledge of the location x i in the
first component doesn't inform um when
it evaluates the final of where it's
only
and uh
and also from the game point of view
for the great point of view you want to
say that
people can do
what so if player i decide to do
something
people can react to it but they can do
whatever they they want so you want to
separate
these two
so
what i am skipping here is
you can write associate cost function to
each player
and
one can it is well known
in the literature that
if you can solve this equation if you
can find smooth solution this is
equivalent to finding a nash equilibrium
for your game and so i am going to skip
the explanation the connection with uh
nash equilibrium and just focus on
the system of pde so that
i have
enough time to cover
over material
now
for system of uh hamilton jacobi a
question
the viscosity solution
doesn't work
well this is
something puzzling and so
what people do
when we are solving this equation we are
looking for small solution
if you are not looking for a small
solution you could propose that various
uh suggestions for weak solution but not
everybody
agree on what is the
correct concept of
we call solution and so here we are
going
after small solution and for arbitrary
time
so for short time if epsilon is strictly
greater than zero since this operator is
non-negative you can believe that for
short time you have existence of sumo
solution and we are going to take that
for granted
now here are the typical questions
i am going to call this
the main field game
with n player
resistance
and uniqueness
solution
to
the main field game
and
for t large
so by that i mean arbitrarity
and
same question
or n equal to plus infinity
so for that i need to tell you what it
mean data
n equal to plus infinity yes
the x superscript i in the second line
for the terminal condition um
is
look at big g
[Music]
i just want to make sure
thank you
so
when i was preparing the lecture i wrote
a v
for the function and now i am writing
you
and
later we will start appearing
to you
so you can see here that
i am dealing with partial derivative and
if i want to go to infinity i have to
tell you what is a gradient in
in infinite dimension
so the gradient
the vasa sun gradient have been defined
by
ambrosio giglian savari that i am going
to propose
a different equivalent definition
which uh
uh
look quicker
to
to be
so many people here
have
used the versatile ingredients so this
one is not different from what people
have used
so let
you
from p2
of rd to r
and i am going to lift
set
your heart
of x
to be
u
of x
push forward the big measure
from 0 1 2 d
so for any x
is in the hilbert space
which is the set of square integrable
function
0
so one can check that
the application is one to one so for
every
uh probability measure finite second
moment i can write them there is this a
random variable x i can write them of
this form and so
that
function is well defined now we are in
flat states
and i can define
what is a subdifferential what is the
super differential i just use taylor
expansion
because i have an inner product
and so we have the following
theorem
which is due to myself
and
if
zeta
if z
is in the subdifferential
of u
hat
x
so one can check that when reset is not
empty it is a convex set
is of minimal norm
then
there exists
psy
from
adi
there is this a unique
file
from adi
to hardy
burrell
such that i have a factorization
z
equal to psi
composition
x
and the furthermore
psi is the limit
when n tends to infinity
the integral
of psi
minus gradient of phi n
square
in
for a sequence
by n
which is of class c infinity of compact
support
and the mu here
is
x
push forward
mentioned
so
this work was motivated by a claimer
yes thank you
so i can approximate psi by the sequence
of a gradient
of
function
so this
was motivated by a claim by pierre louis
leon
who said that
if
your heart is differentiable in the
neighborhood of x
then you have this factorization
but when you are working with viscosity
solution
you don't assume that you have a
differentiability even at the point you
work with sub differential and super
differential
and when you give up the fact that
your function is continuously
differentiable in the number of tests
you make a one-page proof become a
10-page
rule
now once i have this
i can choose that as
the definition
of my gradient i can call this the
gradient the reason is if the
subdifferential and the super
differential are non-empty
they coincide and so when i taking an
element of minimal numbing without
differential
it is unequivocally well defined because
if one of them is empty i am fine if
both are not empty i am working with the
same set
so as a done in converse analysis i am
going to define
define
psi
to be the versus time gradient
of you
and it coincides with the gradient
people who have used
here
during this
so take a smooth function
good luck
let u
be
from p2
of
rd
and assume that my function is
differentiable everywhere
and the set
u n
of x one
x n
to be u
of one over n
is from i from one to n
delta
so
if you look at laplacian
u n
of x
if you assume that
one over n
sum
delta s i
from one to n
converges to mu
and so i am going to put
an n here
then
this
converges to
the integral
over rd
the divergence with respect to q
so i am taking q
in rd
the divergence will reset to q the
versus n gradient
of
u
mu
so you can check that
this is
what happened
and
similarly
you can compute
this
limit so i am going to call visa
oh
oh you're new
this is the individual noise
operator
and if you look at the sum
k
the trace
the second derivative
s j
s k
u n
of x n
this will converge to
so the part where k equal to
j it converts to o
of u of mu
and the second part will be the integral
over
rd cross rb
i am going to differentiate twice
you
this is going to produce two arguments s
and y let's call it
q
in cuba
udq
and uh i am going to call this
partial laplacian
of you
so this is a common noise
this is on a geometric object because
you can show that
if you take this to be linear form i
mean you can just read it from here if
you take this to bilinear form and you
apply it to the constant vector
the constant base then you you get
this you can also do the same thing you
take your function
you interpolate
your writer
identity
plus t
e i
push forward mu
you use this interpolation you
differentiate twice you get this object
and so it is a partial
laplacian which are this information
turn out to be
uh helpful in
over work which i am not going to
talk about
now
when we let the n go to infinity
we'll be looking for particular solution
we'll be looking for you
such that
ui
of x
so i don't i don't need to
justify that i can just write my final
uh
equation which is what pl leon did and
then look at my final equation and say
if i set ui to be that then it will
satisfy that equation so what i want to
emphasize is
you can view this
passage to infinity as
not searching for very general solution
but searching for a particular class of
solution
now proving that
this
system of
finitely many particles
converted to the infinite system this is
another difficult problem which to be
able to achieve that you need to show
that a question i have not written has a
small solution so if you think about the
finite element uh method when you want
to prove a rate of convergence if you
know that the limiting equation has a
good smoothness property then you can
compute your rate of conversion and this
is exactly the same thing
here yes
right for the limit as then goes to
infinity would it
yes
okay so let me write what is the so
called
master
equation
master equation
is find you
from
zero t
plus rd
plus we set a probability measure
and rd
into r
such that
dtu
of t
q
mu
minus
the integral
over
rd
gradient p
h
you
and
new
inner product
with
the bassist ingredient
u
t
q
mu
d mu
so this is the directional
derivative
term
and uh
i need to say
something so this computation which i
made i made them for function depending
only on a new now if i have function
depending on q and mu it is going to
introduce some extra term so
i am going to write the plus epsilon
the
individual noise operator
u
plus beta
the common noise operator
u
c
q
mu
plus h
plus minus h
mu
with the terminal condition
u
of capital t
ct
so you can check that
if you restrict yourself
to the to direct masses foreign
average of direct masses you can check
that you get a hyperbolic system
and so this tells you that there is no
way you can expect a smooth solution for
a large time right because even in
finite dimension
we
we know that there is no small solution
for a lifestyle unless we have some
structural condition
so
first theorem on this
was due to
the alligator
flowery
assume
it is separable
h of
q
p
mu
can be written as
h of
q p
plus f
of
q
yeah
and
g
and h are monotone
so this mean
what
it mean that
if i write the expectation
of
g
of
psi one
mu1
minus g
of psi 2
mu 2
this is bigger than or equal to
the expectation
of g
psi 1
mu 2
if i change the order plus g
of
psi 2
mu 1
if
mu i
is the law
of
psi i for i
equal to 1
and 2.
and you can write this in term of
differential
equation which i am not going to do
because i don't have
enough time
then they proved that
for epsilon greater than zero
the mean field in
the unique
solution
i have a theorem
with a
virus
if
is a displacement monotone
and i am going to define what it means
no separability required
and
c
is displacement monotone
then
we have a unique solution
so
displacement monotonicity
mean that the expectation
the expectation
of
the gradient with respect to q
of t
try one
you want
minus the gradient with respect to q
g
by 2.
multiply by sine 1 minus i2
is greater than
or equal to 0.
so i have how long i have that
so for example
f of q mu
give a convolution
last three leones
the second derivative of the fourier
transform
is non-negative
and displacement
mean
second derivative
so for instance if you take a
phi of z
equal to z square
over two
negative five is what give
last three
and five
is what gives
the class of you have some intersession
in the class of
displacement monotony last really a
monotone but they are not the same
set
would you put them together add now two
functions and what is the class that you
think then
so
you can show that
this condition
is equivalent to
gradient x mu
plus gradient q q
is greater than zero
displacement monotone
and this is
the three line
this is greater than zero
so if i want to give you counter example
i play with this i take a function
depending on
q i can drive the value of a private
value down to create displacement
monotonicity or destroy the three linear
monotonicity
so when you write a second order
expansion
of
this
you see that
this is what up here and the second of
the expansion of it here you see that
this is what up here
everything has to be smooth
otherwise we don't know the concept of
solution if
a smooth solution
a short short time
for a short time you have a
small solution even without displacement
monotonicity right so these are
long-term results this is an arbitrary
yes right
uh
since we snuck in some questions there
at the end i want to try to keep us on
schedule maybe i'll uh
uh ask you if you have further questions
you can
talk about later
okay so we have one final talk
over connected